today's technology is great in all but
sometimes you long for those simpler
more pixelated times now that's more
like it
hey come back here we need to save the
princess you two can go back 30 years in
time with Nintendo's new magical little
box this is the $60 Nintendo NES classic
edition and inside are 30 of the
original Nintendo games
yes Super Mario Brothers 1 2 & 3 once
the best will argue in another video yes
Selda yes Donkey Kong
yes pac-man putting this little box in
your living room couldn't be easier Plus
Nintendo shrunk it so you feel old and
enormous here's how it works you plug
the box into the wall then you plug the
box into your TV or monitor via HDMI
then you plug the included controller
into the front of the system and boom
you've got a selection of 30 games to
choose from
sadly no game cartridges to blow on but
if you're feeling super old-school you
can select a CRT filter or a four by
three mode so Nintendo pretty much made
the perfect nostalgia gadget but some
things could be better for one there's
only one controller in the box
even though there are lots of two-player
games it will work with Wii controllers
and you can also buy a matching
controller for 10 dollars then the
chords are hilariously short these are
only two and a half feet long if you
don't get a longer HDMI or power cord
you basically need to sit on your TV the
worst part about it trying to find one
they're sold out at Gamestop Walmart and
all other retailers but before you buy
one on eBay
Nintendo says there will be a steady
flow of additional systems through the
holiday shopping season and into the new
year until then